viewed as peacemaker and reformist by
his supporters ashraf ghani hoped to
rebuild afghanistan after years of war
as with many in his country conflict and
foreign invasion saw him spending most
of his young adult years abroad
in lebanon he studied political science
then anthropology in new york where he
became an economist at the world bank
he was in the united states during the
september 11 attacks in 2001
which turned him to politics
several months later he returned to
afghanistan after the u.s led invasion
and subsequent fall of the taliban
as finance minister he led an attempted
economic recovery carrying out extensive
reforms my country is dominated by drug
economy and a mafia
textbook economics does not work in my
context and i have very few
recommendations from anybody as to how
to put together a legal economy the
poverty of our knowledge must become the
first basis of moving forward ghani gave
up his u.s citizenship in 2009 to run
for president
in 2014 he was voted into office
but there were accusations of fraud
ghani wanted to reform afghanistan but
national dialogue and peace always faced
serious challenges
if we want to have rule of law the high
level officials who are involved in
corruption should be removed so we can
have a transparent judicial system
as the economy struggled and conflict
with the taliban continued ghani's
authority took a hit
he was shut out of talks between the
taliban and the u.s and qatar
in 2020 ghani was re-elected as
president his win again over shadow by
accusations of fraud his main rival
rejecting the result
after the u.s announces plans to pull
all its troops out of afghanistan by
september 11 this year
the fight for control in afghanistan
reached new heights
the president standing firm
brothers and sisters there is no deal
and no will to surrender there are two
choices either to live with dignity or
to live with insult
with the taliban reclaiming provinces at
a swift speed and scale gani blamed the
u.s for departing abruptly leaving
afghanistan's security to struggle and
disintegrate
at the funeral of the government's
assassinated top media official ghani
took a hard stance against the taliban
everyone should know that we are
standing in our place like a mountain
their ways will be broken because they
have no message other than evil they
fill coffins with young people and send
them like savages we stand for the
humanity life and dignity of afghanistan
speaking to parliament ghani said
afghanistan would be back under
government control within six months
but in the days that followed provincial
capitals continue to fall
the taliban's offensive has caused a
mass exodus among foreign government
workers and also afghanistan's middle
class who had the money to escape abroad
but among those less fortunate there's
mass displacement and soldiers have
surrendered
the u.n says the number of civilians
killed or wounded in just two months is
the highest recorded since 2009 raising
concerns of a humanitarian crisis
the speed and success of the taliban's
advance astonished ghani's government
and the western leaders that supported
him with little incentive for compromise
talks backed by the u.s and its allies
between the warring sides failed to
reach a potential peace deal
for gani only time will tell
but it is a result that will always
color his legacy with the prospect of
peace now looking like a catastrophic
failure for all those involved
chilean wolf al jazeera